salve youtubers benvenuti a questa nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consigliarvi un canale e
il canale di calca minime che è geniale
e un ragazzo veramente geniale veramente
molto molto
bravo in quel che fa e io vi consiglio
di iscrivervi perché noi praticamente fa
cover di canzoni famose però
aggiungendoci effetti grafici molto
belli tipo sdoppiamenti effetti clone
ma non solo c'è effetti clone ma usati
in modo artistico
io vi consiglio di andare a vedere come
primo video uno dei suoi ultimi che è
quello della
della cover della della colonna sonora
di the trees del videogioco tetris
andate a vedere perché uno è una cover
bellissima due i video è stupendo dir
poco quindi iscrivetevi in tanti proprio
disintegrate gli la bacheca di iscritti
e ditegli che vi ho mandato io detto
questo iniziamo a inizio presentandovi i
miei nuovi amici
i brufoli che non so se si vendono
purtroppo per una volta che c'è una
buona illuminazione mi si vedono tutti i
brufoli in faccia mi sono usciti tutti
tutti in una volta non so come mai spero
gradiate la loro presentano perché io
non ci riesco
il film che voglio il cile oggi è verde
nic o pardini credo sia per di nick ma è
più bello di empire the mic un film del
2008 diretto da scusate lo leggo perché
impronunciabile james cullen
ok il budget di questo film ei 10mila
dollari nulla c'è praticamente nulla
quindi poteva essere benissimo un film
amatoriale l'avrei lasciato lì è è un
film amatoriale niente no invece no nel
2008 è stato fatto nel 2010 e in tutto
2010 stato prima e portato in alcune
sale americane ma proprio giusto una
decina in tutta l'america seconda è
stato sempre 2010 e rilasciato in dvd
quindi è in commercio quindi abbiamo
tutto diritto di insultarlo o in questo
caso dividere come degli psicopatici la
trama di belve nick è molto semplice
questo film vorrebbe anche essere un
film
ambientalista diciamo perché
praticamente ad un certo punto del film
vi farò vedere le aquile lea perché
parte come una storia d'amore ad un
certo punto del film tutte le aquile
americane attaccavo questa cittadina
attaccano le persone uccidono le persone
il motivo fino alla fine del film non si
sa e qui si scopre che è a causa del
riscaldamento globale perché da quel che
ho capito
a causa dell'inter il riscaldamento
globale dalla terra fuoriescono alcuni
gas che entrando a contatto con le
aquile ne fanno impazzire far uccidere
le persone quindi come avrete capito i
protagonisti di questo film sono uccelli
lo so
fate i doppi sensi che volete tirateli
fuori subito così non così posso dire
uccelli per tutta la recensione in pace
senza che voi pensiate acque i tipi di
uccelli ma io intendo i pennuti
maliziosi finito ok partiamo con i
numeri
davvero 5 regia io ve lo dico subito
tenetevi forte perché questo film e
spassosissimo la regia la regia
tecnicamente proprio te a livello
tecnico è
semplicissima ci sono due perché parlano
in quanto prima uno poi l'altro poi uno
poi l'altro poi uno poi l'altro chi fa
film amatoriali sa che quando tu hai una
telecamera sola e deve inquadrare prima
uno poi l'altro prima uno poi l'altro il
suono che la telecamera registra e sarà
diverso quando in quadri 1 e rispetto a
quando in quadri altro quindi quando
molti tutto insieme si sente il distacco
tra quando in quadri un e quando in
quadri altro
anche qui succede questo
vai
come io vecchio
album back
e parecchio parecchio parecchio
fastidioso veramente tanto c'è non è
possibile che in una scena di due minuti
ci siano salti da audio salti di
inquadrature ma proprio a volte non è
che l'audio diverso da una scena
all'altra salta completamente ignorato
le scene mute
audio più alto audio più basso è un
disastro come non citare poi la scena
della spiaggia dove il vento fa talmente
tanto casino che non si riesce a capire
cosa dicono agli attori
i soldi
che poi sarà perché come potete vedere
le immagini della telecamera sono molto
pulite molto curate il montaggio e
l'audio sono stati lasciati a marcire
così come venivano
lo 4 recitazione da questa recensione in
poi ho voluto creare un piccolo motto
una piccola su diletta per quei film che
hanno nei cinque punti della classifica
la recitazione perché se uno dei sei
scemo film honey 5 punti la recitazione
perché la recitazione non è di livello
infimo è proprio quel tipo di
recitazione che ti vien voglia di
prenderlo una bottiglia spaccata su un
avere sulla scrivania prende i coach che
a parte ii nella gola perché questi
attori che recitano così male
sicuramente avranno mangiato il risotto
con le erbe e il risotto con herbert e
i protagonisti fondamentalmente sono due
la gnocca e il figo la ragazza ancora
ancora se la cavicchia recitare non è
niente di speciale ma è molto naturale
mi vedo salvai chi fornisse
stimolati senso è piazzata in famiglia
il problema è lui
rossi
saltano ps
mi raccomando non muovere troppo le
sopracciglia perché poi sembra che
leciti e mi raccomando poi c'è una
scenetta piccolissima dove durante gli
attacchi degli uccelli che io preferirei
non farvi vedere subito e li faccio
vedere quei dop per capire perché c'è
una scena dopo che gli albi sceglie dove
trovano due macchine fermi in mezzo alla
strada con tutti i conducenti morti ma
dentro le macchine ci sono due bambini
ancora salvi allora li portano con loro
e se li portano via in macchina non
vorrei dire perché io so chi sono
bambini quindi non è che possono essere
andati a corsi di recitazione
per oh mio dio un attimo di pato ma
proprio niente anno
e amici
mi sa che anche i bambini hanno
assaggiato il risotto di prima
numero 3 45 minuti
scusate il film come si chiama verde
bieber demi che vuol dire epidemia degli
uccelli tradotto sarebbe una parola fusa
che vuol dire bird uccelli epidemic
epidemia epidemia di uccelli
ok non pensavo di
poterlo mai dire ma se io guardo un film
chiamato per the mic mi aspetto di
vedere tanti uccelli
il film dura un'ora e mezza il primo
premuto si vede dopo
45 minuti di film che tra l'altro i
primi 45 minuti sono una delle storie
d'amore più fasulle finte e forzate che
abbia mai visto in vita mia basti
pensare che i protagonisti la prima
volta che si vedono lui li guardo al
sedere che poi a chi frega di vedere lui
che trova lavoro lui che vince il lavoro
lei che va dalla mamma lui che viene
presentata la mamma il loro primo
appuntamento loro che vanno al
ristorante non gliene frega nulla a
nessuno
numero due pennuti
impegnati di questo film ok siamo
arrivati a uno dei punti cruciali di
tutto il film
secondo voi sono stati fatti al computer
o sono dei pupazzi se avete risposto
pupazzi magari magari fossero stati dei
pupazzi mi sarei accontentato anche i
passi più squali anche di dodo
dell'albero azzurro mi sarebbe bastato
anche lui ma io in tutta la mia vita non
ho mai visto una schifezza di computer
grafica più schifosa di questo qui è
qualcosa di indescrivibile io se vi
faccio vedere le immagini non serve
neanche il commento vi giuro che non
serve neanche il commento ok 32 no serve
una cosa arrivo subito arrivo subito
e qui mi chiede d'acqua
se avete dell'acqua portata di mano per
favore prendetevi un bicchiere perché
qua serve per forza quella la classica
cosa che si fa con il bicchiere d'acqua
quando vedi qualcosa d'inaspettato 3 2 1
oddio o il fatto
cioè
solo appiccica sembrano appiccicati
sopra la pellicola dopo ma sono fatte al
computer quindi non lo farò delle
immagini ferme sono proprio animati ma
sono poi messi nella pellicola così male
ma così male che vengono fuori con
valgono la rai come è come quando vi
ricordate quando che ne so e c'è quella
immagine di prospettiva dove per esempio
io faccio così sembra che la mia mano
sia più grande
della mia testa e sembra che le mie vita
tengano la mia testa è lo stesso
identico
la stessa identica emozione che mi da
guardare questi uccelli qui
guardate come combattono il c è il libro
dei buonisti
news tv
epico non c'è nulla da dire e o epico
non è anche la mente più malata
riuscirebbe a partorire una cosa del
genere neanche se tu dici proprio di
fare il film più brutto del mondo ma non
ti verrebbe mai in mente di fare delle
scene del genere sono qualcosa di
strabiliante chi vi lancia una
maledizione
chi non ha visto questo film deve morire
perché tutta l'umanità deve sapere di
questo film è bellissimo toglietevi
veramente q3 ho la mia nuova divinità e
jeans
questo è uno dei pochissimi film che mi
ha divertito anche guardandola da solo
ma io non posso neanche immaginare come
sarebbe stato guardando con un'altra
persona ve lo giuro se dovessimo fare un
mega raduno di tutti i nodi youtuber di
tutte le persone che seguono kay kay e
che mi seguono le card uno di 30 mila
persone andiamo in uno in un drive in
all'aperto ci mettiamo lì seduti con le
patatine e il primo film che portiamo è
questo bel david maledetto
numero 1 il finale ma non c'è molto da
dire qua non è proprio una cena c'è e
squallidissimo ma una cosa
squallidissima il finale ma mi ha dato
una tenerezza che questo finale una
tenerezza di quanto fosse brutte putrido
che non ce l'ho fatta c'è un robot
pianto mi sono alzato ho fatto una
standing ovation ha solo la lola fatto
tutto da solo perché era qualcosa di
magistrale ad un certo punto del film le
aquile vanno via da sole senza che sia
successo niente del film all gianluca
detto ma noi andiamo avanti se avrà
detto andiamo avanti finché non ci
rompiamo le palle poi fai finire tutto
in mandi via le aquile nella state le
aquile come abbiamo visto prima
attaccano e uccidono gli umani e
soprattutto si schiantano come
giapponesi durante la seconda guerra
mondiale con gli aerei e esplodo il sun
a cui rispondono portate il fuoco
guardate il fuoco il fumo non ha fatti
tutto questo tutte le persone morte e la
cittadina che con quelle aquila è
diventata praticamente per l'albo nel
1941 come si comportano le persone
festeggiano al fatto che finalmente
l'apocalisse è finita no si abbracciano
come se nulla fosse successo guardano il
romantico orizzonte e le aquile che se
ne vanno via
come se non bastasse guardate le aquile
guardate bene bene bene le aquile si
muovono come se dovessero andare via ma
sono ferme solo animazioni tempo ci si
animano e leali ma le aquile rimangono
grandi uguali perché sono ferme non
riuscivano a far l'animazione che
andavano via sono ferme dopo questo
potrei non guardare neanche più un film
squallido veramente anche la
o no
e schiacci